[Müzik]
şimdi E tedex İstanbul'da olmanın benim
olmamın isterseniz önce çok kısacık ona
değineyim bir nedeni var bu İstanbul
ekib tedex İstanbul ekibinin sevimli bir
ekip bu çok tatlılar ama bir Avcı bir
başlarında bir ekip lideri var çok fena
bana bir taktı böyle şimdi gelecek
benden sonra o da konuşacak bir gün
konuşuyoruz Ben kendimle ilgili bir
şeyler anlattım Aa Hocam dedi bunları
anlatın işte Gelin 19 Mayıs'ta dedi Siz
dedi bu Bunları anlatmadık anlatmak
zorundasınız dedi Dedim ki yani Allah
aşkına Özge benim sı Adan Bir Hikayem bu
bana ait bir şey ne yapsın insanlar bunu
dinleyip dedim olur mu hocam dedi
anlatmanız lazım dedi çünkü ben şöyle
bir şey söylemişim cümle arasında
yapılamaz Laa inanmıyorum demişim nasıl
bir büyük laf ettiysem Bugün kendimi
burada buldum Sizin karşınızda Demek ki
Konuşurken biraz benim dikkat etmeyi 50
yaşıma geldim ama öğrenemedim hala
öğrenmem gerekiyor ama çok mutluyum
burada sizlerle bugün birlikte
olabildiğim için ve Ankara'dan Geliyorum
şimdi Tabii Eee yapılamaz Laa
inanmıyorum demek Eee üniversitede 29
yıl çalışıp ve ardından emekliliğini
alıp bambaşka bir yaşamın içine Eee
kendini kanalize etmiş biri olarak size
Ne söylemeliyim ya da ne söyleyebilirim
i de düşündüm açıkçası gelmeden önce ve
şöyle bir şey çıktı karşıma kendimle
ilgili aslında zaman zaman Eee kendimize
ne yaptığımıza dair
geçen süreye yaşamımızda geçirdiğimiz
Eee özellikle meslekte Ya da aile
yaşamımızda bazı soruları galiba
sormamız gerekiyor Ben de şöyle bir
şeyle karşılaştım kendimi bu şekilde
değerlendirdiğimiz ö geçmişleri var hele
bu özgeçmişler şimdilerde linkedin denen
bu bir sosyal medya mecrası var orası
bir özgeçmiş deposu gibi tabii Başka
amaçlarla kullananlara da zaman zaman
ben rastlıyorum ama orada Eee herkesin
özgeçmişi var ve bakıyorum Öz
geçmişlerimiz Aslında sözcüklerden
ibaret değil
Eee neler yaptığımızı yazabilir O Öz
geçmişler ama bizim Eee orada yazı
anları gerçekleştirirken
yaşadığımız acıları hissettiğimiz
mutlulukları yansıtmıyor sözcüklerin bir
hikayesi yok aslında Dolayısıyla ben de
benim de bir özgeçmişim var meslek
sahibi biri olarak ama onu biraz O
noktaya nasıl geldi bir özgeçmiş
oluşturabilecek duruma nasıl geldim
Aslında biraz onu size anlatmayı istedim
Bugün o yüzden de geldim Ama şöyle bir
kültürümüz de yok bizim Biz kendimizi
anlattığımız zaman yanlış
değerlendiriliyor denir ki arkamızdan
Ben biliyorum böyle şeylerle
karşılaşıyorum ve dikkat etmeye
çalışıyorum Aman kendimden o kadar çok
bahsetmeye yani kadına da bak geldi
Buraya durmadan kendini Anlattı anlattı
gitti diye arkanızdan söylenebilir böyle
bir kültürümüz yok eleştiriliyor
kendimizden söz ettiğimiz zaman
A şimdi ben tabii şöyle bir şey söylemek
istiyorum size kendimle ilgili bir kere
öncelikle ben çok fena İflah olmaz bir
öğrenciyim bu öğrencilik işinden hiç
Vazgeçemedim sürekli bir şeyleri öğrenme
peşine düşüyorum fakat şöyle bir şey de
yapıyorum ardından öğrendikten sonra bir
de Eğitmen tarafım devreye giriyor Dur
ben bir de bunları anlatayım başkalarına
başkaları da bunu bilsin derdine
düşüyorum
Eee Tabii bu iyi bir şey mi bazen zor
durumlarda kalıyorum
Eee çaresi olmayan bir gevezeyim sus
susmuyorum maalesef susmuyorum Bu da
Elimde değil galiba e yaşam bu ülke bizi
ya da beni diyeyim kendi koşullarım
içinde buna zorladı fazla konuşuyorum
Eee çok fena bir sosyal medya severim
onu söyleyeyim bunun için üniversitede
görev yaparken çok eleştirdim a kadına
da bak Koskoca dekan gitmiş Bir de
Twitter'da şey yazıyor gibi eleştiriler
aldım Evet İflah olmaz bir sosyal medya
severim Şu aralar periskopu keşfet ettim
gezegen Mehmet söz etti bir dijital
Devrim yaşıyoruz bu dijital devrimin de
dışında kalırsak sanıyorum çok da
varlığımızdan o kadar kolay söz
edemeyeceğimiz günlerden geçeceğiz
Önümüzdeki e süreçte Dolayısıyla orayı
keşfettim Ama çok amaca yönelik bir yer
onu da söyleyeyim hangi amaçla
kullandığınızda çok ilintili Eee dediğim
gibi Ben şimdilerde Eee üniversitedeki
maceralı akademik Eee yolculuğum sonra
oradan ayrıldım bir kamu Üniversitesinde
görev yaptım Ankara Üniversitesi'nde 29
yıl ve kendi işimi kurdum dedim ki bunu
da ne olur yanlış algılamayın Ben de
başlı başına bir Akademi olabilirim
bundan sonra belki dedim bunu denemek
istedim Çünkü bu benim hayalimdi bunu
yapmayı istedim ben kendi işimi kurdum
ve bir şeyler yapmak istiyorum
öğrendiklerimi e tekrar başkalarına
aktarmak istiyorum ama ama bunların
dışında ne yapıyorum en sevdiğim rolüm
anneliğim onu söyleyeyim şurada
gördüğünüz
e iki genç kadın 23 ve 24 yaşındalar
Onların annesi olduğum için çok mutluyum
ve onlar benim bugün en iyi dostlarım
Eee müthiş bir köpeğim var onun da
annesi gibi hissediyorum kendimi çünkü o
beni Annesi biliyor zaten Eee harika bir
ufaklığın
halasıyla hasta Parkinson hastası ve
demansı olan bir geçmişte çok zeki ve
çalışkan olan bir kadının kızıyım böyle
rollerim var ama bunların dışında ben
Eee başka bir şeyler de yaptım E hayat
beni başka bir noktadan başka bir
noktaya taşıdı bazen başladığınız yerde
Eee ailelerin Hali vakti yerinde olsa da
çocuklarının bir işte çalışmalarını
isterlerdi yaşama hazırlansın ve
öğrensinler bir şeyler diye Eee ben de o
kapsamda çalıştım annemle babamla
babamın iş yerinde yardım ederek Hep
çalıştım
Eee bundan sonra da şöyle bir şey oldu
Eee başarılı da bir öğrenciydim ama çok
da pısırık dım hep dayak yer falan
gelirdim okuldan Eee ve benim annem de
bana derdi ki yani ne biçim bir çocuk
evde hiç durmuyorsun susmuyorsun ama
okulda Sesin soluğun çıkmıyor sopa yiyip
geliyorsun derdi böyle bir
çocuktum birdenbire üniversite sınavı
dönemi geldi ve şöyle bir şey yaşadım Bu
salonda bunu yaşamayan var mıdır
bilmiyorum her aileye bir doktor lazım
Bunu da sen yapmalısın dediler Benim
dönemimde 18 tercih yapılırdı Benim 16
tercihim Tıp Fakültesi oldu ve ben sonuç
itibariyle sınavın sonunda iyi bir anla
dımdızlak ortada kaldım giremedim bana
dediler ki doktor olacaksın Oysa ben ya
sosyolog ya edebiyatçı olmak istiyordum
ben ne istediğimi biliyordum ama ailem
Benim ne istediğimi bilmiyordu
Dolayısıyla ben açıkta kaldım ve
birdenbire kendimi Ziraat Fakültesinde
buldum nereden nereye orayı bitirdim İyi
de bir dereceyle bitirdim o zaman bundan
30 yıl önce sakın milattan önceyi gibi
bakmayın yüzüme böyle alti yabancı
puanyayın gözüne
girmişsin vardı Onunla ilgili bir fırsat
yakalamış oldum O hayalimi söyleyeceğim
size ben Radyo çocuğuyum öyle dijital
devrimle 40'lı yaşlarımda tanıştım Eee
Aramızda o dönemi bilen var mıdır
bilmiyorum TRT1 ve TRT 2'de trt1'de
pazar günleri TRT 2'de hafta içi her
akşam üzeri mikrofonda tiyatro olurdu ve
ben bütün klasik eserleri orada dinledim
çok değerli oyuncularla
dinledim televizyonun siyah beyaz olduğu
dönemde 8 yaşımda televizyonla ve
ahizeli telefonla tanıştım ve şu
telesafir denen şey gerçekti arkadaşlar
10 12 kişi evinde televizyonu olan
ailelerin komşuların evinde toplanır
çaylar içilir Türk Sanat Müziği Türk
Halk Müziği koroları koroları izlenirdi
o dönemde Ben öyle bir dönemden geldim
30'lu yaşlarımın ortasında bilgisayarla
tanıştım 40'lı yaşlarımın başına doğru
internetle tanıştım ama şimdi
vazgeçemediğim olanaklar Bunlar ki böyle
olması
gerekiyor o dönemde radyoda spiker soru
sorar bir üniversite hocası çıkmıştır
radyoda konuşur işte sorduğu soruya
spikerin cevap verir bilmiş bilmiş Ve
ben hep gözümde şunu canlandırdım işte
topuz saçlı gözlüklü siyah ceket etekli
bir kadın Eee ve konuşuyor ben de böyle
olacağım Büyüyünce ben de bu işi
yapacağım derdim Bir de baktım
üniversiteyi bitirdiğimde hiç
istemediğim bir yeri bitirdiğimde böyle
bir fırsatla karşılaştım Ben sosyolog ya
da edebiyatçı olacaktım sonra bitirdim
ve bir gittim sosyal bilimlerde yüksek
lisans ve doktora yaptım Onunla da
yetinmedim ama bu arada da sisteme hiç
uygun biri değilim Sürekli problem
yaşıyorum Danışman hocamdan işitmediği
laf kalmıyor öyle bir süreçten de
geçiyorum Neyse çok uzatmayacağım aradan
zaman geçti
eee bir şey daha yaptım bunları Tabii
Master yapmadan önce yaptım Allah'ım ben
bu adamla evlenmeliyim dediğim adamla
evlendim böyle bir şey yaşadım ve
e o insanla bir kitap fuarında çarpıştım
Sonra bir baktım bir gün derse gelen
hoca oymuş birdenbire hocam kocam olu
verdi
Sonra öyle oldu yani bunu eleştirmeyin
insanların başına her şey geliyor
Eee sonra Kader durmuyor bir ters bir
düz bir iyi bir kötü sizinle ilgili bir
sürü şey yapıyor o harika adam 2002
yılında Türkiye'nin içinden geçtiği bamb
başka bir sürecin Eee sonucunda
öldürüldü evimizin kapısında evimizin
önünde öldürüldü Ben başka bir mecraya
doğru gittim bundan sonra çok genç bir D
Doçent o dönemde sonra bütün bunları bir
yana bıraktım 10 ve 11 yaşında harika
iki Bebecik le ve koskoca bir travmayla
baş başa kalmıştım dedim ki bunlar bir
kenarda durmalı ve Ben bununla başa
çıkmayı akademik bir biçimde öğrenmek
zorundayım bunu aramanın bunu keşfetme
yolunu aradım ve bununla ilgili gördüm
ki batıda çok ciddi çalışmalar var ciddi
sertifikalı kurslar programlar
Seminerler var ve ben tek tek bunlara
gitmeye başladım bir süre sonra ne oldu
biliyor musunuz Ben
Eee lisanslı bir yas danışmanı olup
çıkıverdin
ortaya ardından şöyle bir şey yaşadım
onu söylemedim demin atladım
Eee zor bir Çocukluğum oldu benim çok
geçimsiz bir anne babanın çocuğuydum ben
ve şiddet de vardı evde ve o ortamda
okula gider bundan bahsetmekten utanır
arkadaşlarıma mutlu aile hikayeleri
anlatır yalan söylerdim Sonra bir
baktım alan değiştirdim sosyal hizmet
alanına yöneldim bu akademik kariyer
ilerlerken yas danışmanlığı başlamışken
ve birdenbire önüme aile danışmanlığı
olmakla danışmanlığı olmakla ilgili bir
fırsat çıktı dedim ki Ya ben bunu da
yapabilirim belki Hadi bunu da bir
deneyeyim dedim Bununla ilgili de bazı
şeyler öğrenmeye devam ediyorum bitmiyor
bu çünkü bir baktım bir süre sonra
ruhsatlı aile danışmanı
oluverdim Ben bunların hiçbirinin
tesadüf olmadığına inanmaya başladım bir
süre sonra emin Çapa ile böyle atışıyor
bana yine bir pas atarak gitti bugün eee
dedi ki hani neydi Türk hamamları Eee
kaldırma kuvveti yoktur gibi bir şey
başlığı var değil mi kimsenin arşimed
olması gerekmiyor arkadaşlar
hayatta ben atomu
parçalamadan için de bugün buraya
gelmedim sadece tek bir şey yaptım Onu
söylemek ve onu paylaşmak için geldim
sizlerle kendimi keşfetmeye doğru bir e
adım attım ve bir kendimi keşfetmekle
ilgili bir başlangıç yapmaya çalıştım
çünkü ben şuna şunun gerçek olduğunu
gördüm arkadaşlar Her başlangıç iyi ya
da kötü herhangi bir olayın sonunda
önümüze çıkan Her başlangıç İnanın ki
ilerlemenin ve gelişmenin en önemli
adayı sizden daha çok aday Her başlangıç
bunu özellikle söylemek istiyorum
Eee Bu
salonda çok sevdiğim ve sosyal medyadan
tanıştığım bir arkadaşım var Çok güzel
bir tweet paylaştı az önce
diyor ki her şeye rağmen
gülümseyin hayat bu belli mi olur her
şey daha güzel olabilir diyor Ben de
İnanır mısınız bunu yaptım Ben çocukken
de çok gülerdim ve annem bana kızardı
hem çok konuşuyorsun hem çok gülüyorsun
derdi Ama zamanla yaşım ilerleyince
Bunun nedenini de çözdüm biliyor musunuz
Hem o mutsuz aile
ortamından kurtulmak için için anlatmak
istiyordum ama aynı zamanda buna yönelik
de bir direnç ve dayanma
Eee yeteneği geliştirmek için de
gülüyordum buna dayanabilmek için de
güldüğümü fark ettim ve sonra şöyle bir
şeye dönüştü gülmek artık benim için
yaşamın en önemli
parçası en zor şey Hele ki yaşadığımız
koşullar altında ama bizi güçlü kılan
bize dayanma gücü veren bir şeyi
gülebilmek Onun için çok önemsiyorum ve
bir şey daha söylemek istiyorum Bu
insanın kendini keşfetmesi yok içine
yolculuk şu bu hani o var ya postmodern
kültürün bireysel gelişim e çorbası
içindeki bir takım ögeler onların
dışında bir şey benim söylediğim Eee
yapılamaz diye bir şey yok Ben bunu
Kızlarıma hem de öğrencilerime de
söylüyorum
eee bir şey yapamam diye bir cümle
kurmadım şimdiye kadar Ama Ama şöyle bir
cümle kurdum Dur bakalım ya nasıl
yapabilirim acaba ben bir de buna
bakayım araştırayım nasıl yapacağım
acaba nasıl bunun üstesinden geleceğim
dedim hep Dolayısıyla şöyle bir şey
çıkıyor o zaman karşımıza bunu özellikle
söylemek istiyorum A yapamayacağımızı
düşünsek de her denememiz istediğimiz
gibi sonuçlandığında Evet yaşamımızda
başarı hanesi olarak görünecektir Ama
inanın istediğimiz sonuçla karşılaşmıyor
Sak Eğer o da bizim yaşamımızdaki
deneyim hanesine yazılacaktır her
durumda başarı söz konusu Deneyim
kazanmak o kadar önemli ki yaşamda
gülerek durmak ve Eee var olmak için
güçlü olmak için deneyim elde etmek çok
önemli başarıyı Ancak bu getiriyor Bir
de şey çok önemli tabii buradan lütfen
ukalalık ettiğimi de düşünmeyin
başarının sınırı yok Göreceli bir şeyi
nasıl tanımladığını bağlı
ama ben yaşadıklarımın bir tesadüf
olmadığını
ve bir nedeni olduğunu fark ettim bugüne
geldiğimde dolayısıyla bir tek şey
söyleyerek bitirmek isterim Her şeye
rağmen Gülümsemek lazım Ve bundan asla
vazgeçmemek gerekiyor Ben böyle
gülüyorum bilmiyorum işe yarıyor mudur
diyeceğim ama galiba yarıyor inanın daha
güçlü hissediyorsunuz O zaman
kendinizi bir şey için tedex istanbul'
da teşekkür etmek istiyorum Benim en
kalabalık eee gruplarım bir anfi dolusu
öğrencilerim oldu Hep Eee bu arenada
olmak da bir hayal onu da söyleyeyim ve
buna fırsat yaratan tedex İstanbul'a da
çok teşekkür ediyorum hele hele sizlere
geldiğiniz için kucak dolusu sevgiyle
teşekkür
[Alkış]
ediyorum